we came all the way up to UCF we're on a
mission to free the slave Minds we got a
little bit of a special guest here
let's get it done patchy fat G in the
building here at UCF yep
I'm sure you heard but Andrew Tate just
got out of prison so what are your
thoughts why did I know it was going to
be a question about Andrew Tate I mean
we got fat G here so maybe that's how
you know it's a freaking G dude you like
them I uh do not why don't you like
Andrew Tate I feel like no one really
does you know I feel like it kind of
goes I like them
you seem like a special guy you know
woman why don't you like him just I feel
like he goes without saying I don't
really want to get into it do you have a
reason
um just because he's kind of an [__]
you know you know what you remind me of
a misandrist
you know what about this interest is
how ironic the people who call him a
[__] misogynist can't even know what
a misandrist is ironic I don't
say you
he's very scary now yeah yeah but you
don't have you're indifferent I mean I
don't listen to him so I don't really
care I did not know he got released from
prison so you like him no why not he's
just not a good person like is there
something that he said that you don't
like there's a lot of things he said but
like I mean I don't remember anything
specifically but he's just like very
disrespectful towards women so what do
you think
I don't know I don't really I don't
really care to be honest I mean it's
pretty cool I don't know
he's a good guy it's top G yeah I kind
of like when she said he's pretty cool
her eyes kind of looked at her for like
instant approval but then she just went
back
like he has a very
um interesting worldview that a lot of
people disagree with and I don't agree
with it either I hold to the Christian
worldview which is that people are made
in the image of God uh and that
everybody should be treated with dignity
um and unfortunately
[Music]
he does say things that implies that
women shouldn't be treated with dignity
in certain situations which is also
incorrect because everyone's made an
image of God including women it's a long
story but somebody sent me a reel on
Instagram it was basically there was
like a woman who was interviewing him
who was like how do you feel if like the
person you're dating has only fans and
he was like well it's okay as long as I
get the money or at least like 80 of it
and he was like saying like it's because
oh like it's my product but the thing is
it's a human being and I also am in the
field of Social Work and
um one of our core values is the dignity
and worth of the person and that type of
thinking doesn't align with that at
least you like have a point a lot of
people don't know why they don't like
them what do you think what do you think
fetchy uh it's very interesting because
uh you know it's the internet people
only see a certain portion but they
don't actually see the whole truth of it
actually and in fact what you're saying
like you have to understand too as a man
if we're providing we're protecting
we're giving you everything you need but
then you're out here on only fans
basically showing your [__] for three
bucks what value do you really have you
know and then you want to treat people
with dignity but then what about all the
women take advantage of all these men in
the world where they use it for their
resources time money attention all that
you know and then those women just go
like haha I broke his heart [__] him
next one so there's there's a big uh big
difference that you have to understand
too as a man and a woman we have two
different roles and uh it's a big factor
[__] that man the man sucks he's just
super super misogynistic you
you kind of sound misandrist you know
that can you define misandrist
misogynist a misandrist no so can you
define misogynist misogynist would be
like masculine formats of feeling like
they're wrong
oh my God I'm being assaulted no no
one's exhausting you no one's assaulting
you but what do you think of being a
misogynistic as a guy is I don't know
people underestimate like the fact that
they're like oh you're just like saying
that everything men do is wrong and it's
not that it's just about having the same
level of respect for each other I don't
think that they need to be like on the
ground like opening doors for me like
get on your knees and like you like it
when guys open the door for you and pay
the bill obviously
but anybody would
for me like it doesn't matter what
gender you
are the I'm in like we split we split
pay and like we go back and forth like
who drives who pays who opens each
other's doors like we should all the
time is that a man with all due respect
uh no it's not they're not female oh
yeah it explains
perfect bad Jeep and awesome that you
have so much more time excuse me guys do
you want to answer a really quick
question for a video
oh okay have a good one
have a great day [__] retards
shut up I'm good don't you know but
don't be rude to this round dude it's
[__] she's coming
oh she's gonna get mad
actually it is that's free speech
well I didn't appreciate you turning us
down for just a moment of your time
and we're having a serious bum here all
right cheers have a good day have a good
day
see that just made you a good [__]
clip we can't include that bro you just
called her a [__] [__] listen way
fetchy so like you're nice to some
people but then some people are also
nice and you just call them retards well
I mean she was being like sarcastically
nice she was like yeah we're having a
conversation you know what I mean so
like [__] that dude
there's no more important than fat G and
top G talking about Justice awesome
[Music]
so we're here with drip the diversity
racial occlusion project and recently
there was an African-American man who
was in jail for three months without any
charges or any evidence against him his
name was Andrew Tate I'm not sure if you
ever heard of him no well you're a
really nice religious man what are your
thoughts on feminism feminism so I would
go by what the Bible says which is it's
clear that God made both men and women
in his own image they're both equally
valuable in the sight of God now do I
think women should be fighting I do I
think there are differences between men
and women yes do I think I design men
and women for different things yes and
so like I support women in the military
not particularly but
looking like a good guy what's your name
I'm David sunny it's great to meet you
pleasure to meet you brother like people
like that actually live by like a good
code in life you know what I mean like
people like that I don't want to [__]
control because in reality those are
good people bro like I respect people
like that what's that mean on your leg
the bitter truth is better than the
sweetest lies cool so you're gonna be
the perfect person for this yeah so
recently there is an African-American
male who was in jail for three months
without being um proven guilty improving
guilty no evidence shown or anything
like that his name is Andrew Tate what
are your thoughts on him being released
from prison
it's an African male that was unjustly
in jail for three months have you heard
of drip our program no yeah it's the
diversity racial inclusion project
we're here to bring Justice to African
Americans that were unjustly persecuted
have you heard of Andrew Tate
unfortunately you don't like them no why
not it's Andrew Tate it's Andrew Tate
like can you like give a reason about
him but can you name something like
like the things that he says
he's bald because he's black
so what is it because you said
everything I'm pretty sure the two
things we said are pretty like 100
positive he's balding he's black so what
is it you don't like because you just
said everything his opinions his views
what like what women the things he says
about women what has he said about women
that you don't like because he has more
Traditional Values I feel like he's very
decoratory towards me
can you define degratory please
like like he's degrades women all right
listen unfortunately ma'am you're being
fed [__] on the media whatever
applications you watch are horrible okay
Tick Tock Instagram YouTube listen you
need to upgrade it because exactly what
your tattoo stands for is exactly what
you're speaking against you're speaking
about bitterness he's actually not a bad
man okay unfortunately we live in a
society as I've said before we're living
in a society that wants everybody to be
gay and wants everybody to move in a
certain direction towards transgenderism
and we're taking everything away from
reality he's making us men men all right
so that women like you who are pretty
can be protected taken care of a big
beautiful life
are you a single by any chance no [__]
thank you what was your name
America
I'm China nice to meet you
we're coming for you have you heard of
Andrew yeah I don't really like him why
not I just
I don't know I just
he's kind of misogynistic but I also
don't really want to like I don't really
have much of an opinion about it so I
don't really want to like I'm a bot
yeah it seems like there's a lot of
people who don't like them but they have
you watched a full podcast of his or
anything so that's why I don't have an
opinion do you think it's a problem to
dislike someone if you haven't watched
all of their stuff and I guess yeah I
mean I guess it's like important to like
educate yourself on stuff but yeah
that's all we're really trying to do a
lot of people don't like them and they
don't know why so we're just getting
people to think about it
she's a bi they're innocent beings man
you know they just see the media and
that's their thoughts so hopefully they
can actually critically think and Kim
Kardashian is my leader I will spread
[__] like that for my leader give me
Ray J dick give me Ray J dick fame fame
fame fame fame fame fame personally I
just felt like he's always misogynistic
and stuff like that but again like I
said I don't really know much about it
so I don't make too much comments what
do you think being misogynistic is
because a lot of this message is like
protecting and providing for women which
is more Traditional Values so I'm
curious what people think is actually
being misogynistic right
um like I said I'm not much very
educated in the topic and stuff like
that but um so misogynistic I just felt
like it was like again like the grading
woman and stuff like that like if that's
what he stands for is like protecting
some of that cool but like I said I
don't really pay attention to it so yeah
that's what he stands for a lot of the
clips that you see are just taken out of
context and then plastered on the
internet and then media titles because
those get the most clicks so if you
haven't paid much attention how can you
come to the conclusion that he's
misogynistic or how can feel he's
misogynistic if again you said you
haven't paid attention to him
a little bit I've seen so like I said
like it's just based off a small small
amount but do you think it's a problem
to have a straw or not even a straw any
judgment on someone if you haven't
ingested their content before in long
form and it's only been short clips
anybody could have a podcast and have 10
second Clips taken out of context you
see you see what I'm getting at yeah no
I know what you're getting at I don't
think it's a problem like I think it's a
problem like if you're like like solely
defending it and like not making it like
aware that you like don't know like if
you're trying to like defend some
situation like pretending that you like
all this info but like I think taking
small Clips like obviously some things
can be taken out of context but as like
a general like first impression like I
don't think it's a big problem but like
if you go on research and find otherwise
as long as you're open to like new ideas
and stuff I don't think it's a problem
okay because like my big thing is I just
want people to think for themselves and
actually be critical thinkers rather
than just seeing Eight Second Clips not
looking for context and simply reading
media titles because both sides do this
it's conservatives and liberals that get
brainwashed by their media so I'm really
just trying to get people to actually
think more that's it put them back in
prison why you don't like them no why
don't you like them because he's stupid
because he's stupid so we should stupid
sure should we throw someone in prison
if they're stupid no just him just him
what has he said that you don't that you
don't like yeah oh that's crazy all
people
that's why I had cancer I'm really sorry
to hear that damn that's wild so wait
why don't you like them I just don't
what do you guys think why don't you
like them because he's awful has he said
anything that you disagreed with no
comment you know what sucks you know it
sucks you women are actually like so
beautiful and so actually like cool
looking but you're so [__]
brainwashed brainwashed brainwashed
you're saying he's awesome
no he's not it was he was actually no
you're good he's actually innocent he's
like literally innocent yeah so he was
just in jail for three months because
they were looking for evidence and then
he just got out because they didn't find
anything yeah do you guys have any other
thoughts when
what was your name
fairness to meet your list I'm Sunny I'm
Melissa I'm a bot I go to school I'm a
bot tick tock tick tock tick tock but
are you Sam bankman freed
you stole all my money bro on FTX man
what the hell because you owe us money
you stole it first that's wild you guys
want to answer a quick question for a
video no
all right have a good one
like like the like the boat of like like
Noah's Ark
yeah animals on this hell yeah do you
put like
do you put the non-binary nose from
there no
I kicked them out
Andrew Tate recently just got out of
prison an African-American man so we're
here collecting people's thoughts on the
situation do you like him no why not why
do you come on you're very pretty girl
you gotta know why because he's a
terrible man what has he done though he
talks down about women all the time have
you ever you guys Andrew supporters I
like Andrew Tate yeah I am definitely a
top tape supporter have you ever watched
a podcast of his no so don't it's my
time so don't you think that's a problem
to claim that this is what he is when
you haven't actually watched him heard
him say compare women to a lock and that
men are the master keys he didn't say
that I don't know but that's actually no
no that's actually a good one because if
you open up your legs for everybody that
means that there's no specialty to it
like there's no like no no it doesn't
have value but look okay what's your
body count
why why are we asking this because
there's a big question because women are
like open locks right where you can have
sex with anybody and then women high
body count bad status a man to have high
body count that's a good thing because
it takes more problem with Society
that's a problem with Society but Andrew
Tate is encouraging this male behavior
that is not good but like what kind of
male Behavior like male behavior that he
can look down on women and treat women
like [__] no but he says to treat women
with even more respect and that they're
more valuable you know
um
what are you in today
so so really quick so let's do karate
come on I need it come on come on come
on
come on but look so what if I told you
what if I told you we're being misled by
social media I don't care Andrew Tate
talks so I've heard actually I have
heard my friend did listen to his
podcast and I would listen to it it's so
dumb it was so dumb Define dumb this way
which one is the fastest way to order
wherever you want Define them this way
yeah can you define dumb he talks down
to women no he doesn't yes he does
Define it I've seen it like I said he
compared women to Locks like we're like
we're objects like don't you think
everybody's an object a human and a male
and female no male and female but that's
an object human beings that's an object
that's not an objects we have
scientifically we have souls uh that's
different personality no actually I
don't have personality I'm fat G no you
have a personality I know it it might
not be a good personality but you have
one if we get 20 000 likes on this video
we're gonna come back to the school and
go around twenty thousand twenty
thousand no no no no no you've been
killing it lately bro they've been
killing it lately I'm thinking like five
thousand all right all right that [__]
40 000. 40 000 sounds great forty all
right fine forty thousand likes and
we'll come back and we'll get people to
sign the put tape back in prison
petition yep and if you sign
your low IQ
peace
[Music]